I certainly probably wouldn't have gone poking at the Great Firewall personally.
I've never been to China, but I'd like to go at least once before I do that.
Alrighty, y'all.
Time for another Threat Locker Lockdown story, okay?
Picture this.
You're on an internal pen test and you finally got a foothold on a target machine.
You've reached the point where it's time to snoop around a little bit and see if you can find these little juicy pieces of information that allow you to pivot deeper into the network.
You open up the desktop and what do you see?
But what every hacker loves to see?
Passwords.txt file.
You type cat or type or whatever it is on Windows to get the contents of that file.
And just as you press enter, the shell drops.
No, why did the shell drop?
That, my friend, was a Threat Locker Canary file.
And that machine is now on complete lockdown.
You're burnt.
End scene.
I know, I know, I know that was traumatic, y'all.
But I had to let you know what kind of things Threat Locker Detect is doing to hackers.
So if you or a loved hacker has experienced trauma at the hands of Threat Locker systems,
please call the Threat Locker Hacker complaint number at 833-292-7732.
All right, guys, let's go.
Back to the show.
All righty, man, here we go.
Chains out, ready to roll.
Get the chain gang going.
I finally got one yesterday.
And I'm feeling it, you know?
It brings an extra level of confidence, I think, to the deal.
It's really bringing your Florida out.
Oh, is it really?
All right.
Well, the hair is extra curly today, too.
So I'm feeling it.
I'm feeling it.
Yeah, yeah.
All right, man.
Well, this week we have a lot of crazy research that has hit the Twitters, has hit the bug bounty
scene.
Jeez, where do we start?
Well, do you want to start with the acid note research?
Because that was pretty crazy.
Yeah.
That one is crazy, for sure.
Every once in a while, there's like, you know, again, there's like a tweet from Shubs.
And it's just be like, oh, yeah, we found this thing.
It's like, how long did you spend looking at this?
Because it's just like months of research.
Yeah.
And he was just casually about it, too.
Like, I think he tweeted out the first time he's like, on the 27th of September or something
like that, we're going to drop some crazy shit.
And then he did.
And so, yeah, dude.
I mean, having read through the whole thing, it's like, I don't understand why the great
firewall of China would implement this this way.
This seems such like a weird thing to do.
But the TLDR of the situation is essentially anything that routes through China from a DNS
perspective is getting DNS poisoned.
And essentially, any keyword, if it contains a specific keyword like web proxy ID, or I think
they listed like 700 something keywords at the bottom of the research.
Then if that is in the subdomain of this any DNS resolution, it will just resolve it to like
a random IP address, a set of random IP addresses.
And where the rubber meets the road with that is that there are vulnerabilities hosted on these
IP addresses, right?
So one of them is vulnerable to a cPanel XSS, and one of them or several of them are actually
IP addresses that point towards a proxy provider that I can't pull out of my brain right now.
Which one was it?
Was it like Proxify?
Fastly?
Fastly.
That's it.
Yeah, that's it.
Yeah, Fastly.
And so you can go on there and just register that domain to your account and almost pull like
what a subdomain takeover would look like.
Um, in these sort of scenarios.
So lots of domains are affected.
And, uh, and it's crazy that they implemented it this way.
Yeah, I mean, it's, it's really wild.
Um, I guess it's one of those attack surfaces that like most people probably just don't touch
out of a variety of reasons.
Uh, I certainly probably wouldn't have gone poking at the great firewall personally.
I've never been to China, but I like to go at least once before I do that.
Um, so, uh, it's just, uh, you know, props to the asset note team because, um, I don't
know if I would ever step foot in China again.
That being said, super, super cool research.
Yeah.
Um, yeah.
I think, I think also, you know, that they, this shows their commitment to their, their,
uh, customers because they're like, yeah, so we onboarded this, this customer and they had
some stuff in China.
And then we realized like, what is all this garbage that we're seeing?
Right.
Like we have to fix this for them.
Um, and then they went down that rabbit hole of fixing it for them.
And that's how they found that this, that this weird edge case was happening.
Right.
Um, so yeah, I think, I think it's, I think it's really solid.
And I think that that shows, you know, when you have such a mass amount of data like asset
note has you, you see these anomalies, uh, if you're looking closely and, um, and you're
able to find cool pieces of research like this.
Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
And it seems like Eric as well, uh, today is new contributed pretty significantly to
this research.
He, he dropped a bunch of, um, keywords and known IPs associated with, um, the ways that
you can poison these, these various domains.
Um, so now that there's a, there's a whole list and there's also what I think a lot of
people might've missed.
And I, they, they put a little disclaimer at the top of the article now, but I don't
think that was there in the beginning is that at the very bottom of this article.
So if you go to like dnspoison.com, it'll redirect to the article.
Um, there's like a little tool and you can just enter a domain.
And it'll be like, yes, that domain is vulnerable.
Oh, here's your XSS.
You know, here's your, here's your ATO, you know, that sort of thing.
Um, and so, uh, I think, I think it's cool that they implemented that right into the blog.
Um, and I definitely think it would be, it'd be cool to see somebody take this off, you
know, off the, the web interface here, put it into a command line tool and spray it across
all the programs.
Like I'm sure Eric is doing, you know, if Eric was involved in the research, then there's
definitely some large scale automation in place, but, um, definitely applicable in a
more wide environment.
Yeah, I definitely do.
Uh, this is something I've seen more and more in like recent blog posts is like an interactive
element, so to speak, or just like, uh, you know, like a form or a table or something that
you can like input about you into and it'll like interactively tell you if it's affected
or whatever.
Um, and it seems like a nice way to make sort of that, that research more tangible.
It's, it's more refined for sure.
You know?
And, um, and I think that with, I've actually noticed that with, and we talked a little bit
about this on the pod a couple of weeks ago, but with cursor and with some of these other
systems that make it so easy to build out these like pretty simple POCs and stuff like that,
I think this will become a lot more common because now I don't have to sit there, write
all this little CSS to make it actually look decent.
I can just say like, do this and then call this function and it just plops it out.
And, and that really, that's really helpful.
Yeah.
Yeah, for sure.
Um, well, speaking of POCs, um, there was this project discovery, uh, blog posts about,
um, there was a Ruby Samuel bypass.
I think the phone was actually in Ruby Samuel, right?
Like the core library.
Well, I don't know, core library, but like the library of Ruby Samuel that is a used by a
lot of different things, including GitLab.
Um, so, uh, it's, it's, you know, Samuel is one of those things.
What was the, the Samuel ramble?
The Samuel ramble, the episode, what was that?
Episode like 48 or something like that.
I don't know.
It was a while ago, but as we have talked about before, Samuel is very, very finicky.
It's easy to shoot yourself in the foot.
There's a lot of verification and signing and hashing and all these sorts of things that
you need to be doing properly in the correct order in a very specific way.
If you do it in the wrong way or you skip a step or you make an assumption, then it's
very easy for an attacker to smuggle, uh, malicious Samuel payload through, through your
server and do, you know, potentially really, really drastic, um, you know, off bypasses,
that kind of stuff.
So yeah.
Episode, episode 46 was what that was when I just absolutely lost my mind on Samuel.
And I just like deep dived that and then just dumped it all on you guys.
Um, so if you're interested in, in learning a little bit more about it, uh, episode 46
for that, but, um, yeah, dude, I think this is really quality research coming out of project
discovery and, you know, we see, we see, um, a lot of great tools obviously come out from,
from project discovery, which is, which is great.
Um, but I think it's also really cool that they have this research division where, where
they're finding, you know, zero days and writing them up and integrating them into the
tools and, you know, releasing nuclei, um, templates for these, these exploits.
So, um, yeah, major, major props to, um, the team over there.
The, the takeaway from, for me on this one was a couple of things, but primarily the, the
biggest one was that when you're doing this SAML signature validation, there has to be
some way for you to select the nodes that you are, you know, you need to be hashing and
you need to be checking the signature on.
Right.
And that is typically done via XPath.
And, um, and when you're, when you're using XPath, obviously you're, you're selecting from
a, uh, an XML document.
Um, and as XML, we, we all know from, from, you know, learning about HTML parsers and XML
parsers and all this sort of thing that that is a very, um, shifty environment.
There's like mutations that will occur from, from one to the other.
Um, and I think trusting XPath to do the selection correctly, uh, is, is definitely, it was something
you have to do in order to be able to, to select the elements out.
But I think there's a lot of wiggle room there.
And if you can get it to select the incorrect element, like it did in this scenario, um, then
clearly a lot of damage can be done.
Uh, so that's something, whenever I review code for SAML stuff in the future, the, the one
takeaway that I'm going to have in my brain from this, from this blog post is like investigate
how they're doing their XPath selections and see if you can, if there's any wiggle room in there.
Yeah.
Well, and I think it's more critically than that.
It's like something as simple as an XPath selection, you might think is not anything complicated,
but you it's, it's a kind of a complex functionality when you think about it, right?
Like you're, you're taking a blob and you're selecting a key from it.
And in the case of XML, there's no guarantee that those keys are unique or what order they're
in or anything like that.
So when the library is naively just saying, Hey, give me this element by this key, you know,
what if there's two of it?
What if, you know, what, you know, how does it select it later on?
How does it compare against it?
Can I put one in a different order?
Can I put one in a different place?
So I think that something as simple as that, it's important to just not take that functionality
for granted.
And there's probably other instances of things that are very, very similar to this, whether
it's JavaScript query selectors or CSS query selectors or XML or beautiful soup or, you know,
there's a ton of different ways that like XPath and these query selector type behaviors is used
all over the place.
And I think, you know, maybe some creative research could be done around how these things are working
and whether or not there's other pitfalls around, you know, that selection process where
you might just be like, Oh, give me that element.
But, you know, sort of like this, like double use or use after free type mentality where
it's like, you know, you're using, you're selecting an element in one place, but like, if you select
it somewhere else, it might come out different.
Yeah.
And I think that, um, that there's that just to even take the principle higher, like you were saying that selection
in general, I think is, is tricky because there's, there's a lot of, a lot of these algorithms for signature
validation or whatever are really vetted and are pretty hardcore, but they, a single point of failure would be
where they're getting their information from.
Right.
Um, and so I think that's, that's a great principle to take away.
The, the other thing that I was reading through this and I was like, yeah, man, this is just kind of weird.
Right after I say all the signature algorithms are vetted and everything, uh, is that, you know, XML or the way that
SAML does the signature validation is the whole SAML response is not signed.
It's the assertions.
Right.
And then those assertions are, are, um, are signed, uh, are, are hashed.
And then that, that list of hashes essentially is then signed.
Right.
And that's how the validation occurs.
Um, so in this scenario, you know, what, what they're able to do is they're able to smuggle
in an assertion by, um, putting in a, a hash in a specific spot that, that isn't a part of the
signature, right?
So it's not something that's going to invalidate the signature.
And when they check to see if the assertion matches the hash, it does because you can just
hash it yourself.
Right.
Um, and then when they go to check the signature, because that, that, um, hash that they
defined is not actually a part of that signature, then the signature still matches because, uh,
nothing inside the signature was tampered with.
Right.
Um, so it, there's a little bit of a disconnect there, right.
With, with how SAML, SAML is, is being validated.
There's like this signed list of hashes and not everything in the, the body of the SAML
response is actually being signed.
So there's some wiggle room for you to sneak in various elements and, and hijack selectors
and that sort of thing without actually affecting the signature, uh, the integrity of the signature
in that, in that response.
Yeah, for sure.
And I, I just find it very interesting in general, like anything that's like sort of
like self encapsulating that, that, that should kind of raise some red flags where like there's
a signature inside the message, but it's excluded from the signature itself.
You know what I mean?
Like it's a signature that represents the message that it's inside of, right.
It's kind of, it's kind of strange behavior because circular, right.
Like on the, on like the server side, like it has to remove that and like calculate,
like, yeah, it's, it's just a weird, it seems a little bit over-engineered.
And so again, I can definitely see how it would be possible to shoot yourself in the foot.
Yeah.
So there's X-Paths.
So two things in my little SAML, SAML trick, you know, folder in my brain right now is, is
the X-Path thing.
And then there's also the XSLT thing that we talked about in the SAML ramble episode where,
you know, you're actually applying these transformations to, um, the, the XML as it's being parsed.
Um, and various different parts of the, the, uh, XML document might be being parsed at, at
different places in different ways.
So those transformations can create mismatches, uh, mismatches.
Um, and so those are definitely two things that I'm going to keep up in the top of my
head, X-Path and, um, XSLT for, for parsing, um, SAML stuff.
Yeah, for sure.
So there's, um, there's a, there, like I said, there's a POC, um, you know, speaking of
POCs, so, you know, they, of course, project discovery released, um, a Nuclea template for
this bug that will scan for it.
I think, I don't know if it only looks for GitLab instances cause that's what was affected
or if it just like kind of looks generically across the board.
Yeah.
It seems like GitLab.
I think it's just, just GitLab by the looks of the query, but, um, you know, that's a,
you know, if you're using Nuclea already, then your template should auto update.
So you'll probably already get this automatically, but yeah, you know, it's definitely some interesting
research.
Um, and, um, GitLab is not the only, the only application that uses SAML.
Yeah.
So right before this episode, Joel was like, ah, Justin, can we delay this a little bit?
I need to go look at something.
Um, so that, that's great.
I love that.
Um, but yeah, definitely more, more widely applicable.
Yeah.
I got to beat the publication of this pod with the, I'm going to have to look right after
this.
Yeah.
You got to go, man.
Um, yeah, so that, that one's pretty solid.
Uh, definitely, definitely a cool write up there.
And I, and I think, um, a lot of this too, you know, they, they, they narrowed this down
to this specific library as well.
And it takes a lot of set up and it takes a lot of introspection to get, um, you know,
to get these libraries sort of isolated away from like GitLab or isolated away from, you
know, whatever piece of software that you're attacking.
But I think if you can isolate them out and just focus specifically on finding vulnerabilities
in the library, um, that can be very widely applicable.
And I think that's another area where AI can really help a lot.
You could just say like, Hey, um, you know, cursor, could you please like stand up a sample,
a SAML application that uses this library?
Right.
And, you know, it, it's ingested all the docs.
It understands how, how to dockerize things and stuff like that.
And if it can spin up that library and give it a, you know, give you a playground where
you can, you know, have a debugger in there and actually see, okay, well, when it does
this expat selection, it's grabbing this, you know?
Um, I think that that, I think that will be really helpful for security researchers as
well, because there's so much friction that comes along with getting your environment set
up, you know, your VMs, your enterprise software stuff.
Um, it just, I think, I think there's a lot of room for improvement there.
Yeah.
And I like, well, two, two funny things.
One, I find it very amusing that the, uh, the nuclei template itself uses expat selectors.
So hopefully they didn't, hopefully they didn't write a bug in there.
Uh, but secondly, like from unrelated to that, from like the, you know, the sort of like
setup process, like you said, like, yeah, I've been setting up a source control application
and let me just say it is quite a process.
Okay.
Not only does it need an insane amount of resources, like literally I spun up this software
and it started and it was like, ah, I only have 40 gigs of RAM.
Oh my gosh.
60 minimum, 60, 60 gigabytes of RAM.
It's like, Jesus.
Oh no, dude.
So it's just one of those things that like, uh, you know, it's a bit of a learning curve
for sure.
I had to set up a bunch of, uh, DNS records and all sorts of like things that, um, aren't
exactly the most glorious stuff to set up.
That's for sure.
Um, but you know, once you get through that barrier, then, uh, you know, there's lots of
research you can unlock afterwards.
So, um, yeah, I think, um, I think that other researchers aren't doing that as much either.
Right.
So we've seen time and time again, that if you take the time, you set up the software, you
get yourself a nice environment.
Um, you're going to find so much more because, uh, it's not as hardened.
And I think a lot of, a lot of newer people, um, they, they, they will shy away from that
because they don't have the confidence that the path they're going down is the right way.
And instead they'll keep slamming their head into very, very, very hardened scope, uh,
because it's just, you know, right on the surface.
Cause that's what everybody looks at.
And, uh, it's really, you're kind of shooting yourself in the foot with that.
I think, um, yeah, I will say like, you know, that grit during when you come across frustrating
things is like, I definitely just see it more as a, okay, if I'm hitting this wall, every
other researcher has also.
So if I push through that, then that narrows the, you know, the competition for sure.
A hundred percent.
Hey guys, our sponsor project discovery has dropped a new tool in collaboration with Google's
own Mandiant team called TLD finder.
Okay.
Picture the sub finder, but for top level domains.
Need I say any more?
Check it out.
Um, all right, let's, uh, let's, let's jump around a little bit on this.
Um, we've got the, I don't know how, how much do we want to talk about this, this media tech
wifi chipset exploit?
Because yeah, I mean, we could speak about it briefly.
So, I mean, so, so basically there was a CVE, um, in the media tech chipset.
Yeah.
Certain media tech chipsets.
Media tech is a chip manufacturer.
They make, um, a lot of wifi chips.
Um, they're used in a variety of different Android devices, um, and IOT devices and, um,
a bunch of their chip sets, um, include, including ones that I think are used in some routers were
vulnerable to a buffer overflow.
I think it was, um, it's quite complicated.
I mean, it's one of those low level, like C++ vulnerabilities, like straight up.
So there's a really interesting in-depth writeup that was, uh, provided by CoffinSec, uh, on
their blog about, you know, how it works and what's affected and the whole background and
discovery process and the payload and everything.
It's very, very good.
Um, I don't think we need to get into the ROP chain specifics.
Yeah.
I was going to say, as I'm scrolling through this, I'm like, you know, we do our best to
condense some of the material on critical thinking into the audio medium, but you kind
of can't just start reading out like exploits like this, uh, on the, on the podcast.
But I do think, so Joel, maybe you can enlighten us with, with regards to this.
Like, um, it's clearly there's some pretty well-formed exploits in there.
Um, what, how would we, how would we apply these?
Are we, are we going to, you know, should we attack IOT devices that, that, um, are we
looking at mobile stuff or looking at IOT devices?
What kind of stuff will this affect?
Yeah.
Mobile and IOT.
I know that there's at least one IOT device out there on the market that uses a MediaTek chip,
although I believe it's a newer version than these.
So I'm not a hundred percent sure if it's vulnerable.
It's something I've been meaning to test.
Um, but that being said, uh, there is a list of, uh, affected known chipsets and software
versions.
I think it was also something like something to do with like the SDK, obviously.
Yeah.
The drivers for it, I think.
Right.
It manifests itself in like a software thing.
So it's not like, uh, purely a hardware vulnerability.
It just affects certain chipsets.
Um, I guess based on the SDK that it uses or something.
But yeah, I think like definitely, if you see it as something that's using MediaTek.
Especially in the 7,000 or 6,000 series and empty chipsets probably would at least try the exploit.
There's, I'm pretty sure there's just a Python script on this GitHub repo.
Yeah, there is.
Um, yeah.
So, um, yeah.
The other thing that's interesting about this, um, is that it was found with fuzzing.
Um, and fuzzing something that I've spent a little bit of time recently looking into.
And I think every once in a while it kind of like pulls its head back up.
Um, but I think fuzzing is still definitely a very, very useful technology and it's not going away anytime soon.
Yeah.
This fuzzer that was used specifically for TCP and UDP fuzzing is called Fuzzotron.
And it's like designed as a network fuzzer.
So this was found essentially black box by fuzzing, um, network, uh, traffic or packets or something to this chipset until it crashed.
And then it was developed into a full exploit, which is awesome.
Yeah, that is pretty rad.
I think, I think once again, something that requires a lot of setup.
Right.
Um, and one thing that I've been kind of toying with Joel is like, how do we, you know, how do we, uh, in this position as, as people that are in the community of researchers and run this podcast and kind of have a little bit of a platform, how do we encourage and help people put in the time and get better ROI to do deeper research like this?
Where you have to set up like this fuzzing harness and you've got to like detect all of these crashes and bloody, bloody, blah.
Right.
Um, that's something that I'm, I'm continuing to, to, to noodle on, but I think it'd be really cool at some point to do, um, grants or something like that.
Uh, and, and have people, you know, just decide, okay, you know, the media tech chipsets are, are very widely used, you know, and it would make sense for us to have, um, you know, a Docker thing set up where we could fuzz this more simply.
Or, or, um, that sort of thing.
So I think it's really cool to see people take the deep dive on that.
And, uh, fuzzing is definitely an area that I, I can improve on.
I, I, I don't, I don't even really use it that much in web.
I do sometimes, but, um, clearly, you know, at, at this binary protocol level, um, especially in light of some of the exploits we've seen lately in, in live hacking events.
Um, there, there is a lot, a lot to be gained there.
Well, on that topic of, um, fuzzing and, you know, finishing exploits and all that kind of stuff, websites, whatever.
There's a lot of connections here.
Oh my God.
Um, uh, there, there's two things that, uh, that were in the list that were really good.
So there's, um, the first one is this, uh, this Kydo plugin from tur, tur, tur.js, tur, tur24, tur, um, on Twitter.
X, sorry.
Um, so basically it's just an AI tool that will generate wordless for you.
I believe so you basically just say, here's a classic bug.
Um, and I don't even think you give it any other input than that, right?
Yeah.
Here's a classic bug and it just goes, here's a list of payloads.
Well, so there, there, there are some, some AI things that we'll address a little bit later down in, in, in that section.
But this one I think is more specifically just for generating word lists based off of, uh, a, a set of, of word lists, you know, the sec list, um, tools from, from Daniel Meisler.
And essentially just management of those word lists within Kydo.
And I think, I think it's great to see that, that released and out there.
Um, but switching to the AI vein, um, the, the, the Kydo plugin that I really wanted to talk about that does AI just so well is the, uh, is Bebex's Kydo 403 bypasser plugin.
Right.
Um, and I think this was actually motivated by the episode that we released on brainstorming proxy plugins.
And Bebex sort of took that and really just implemented it perfectly, man.
So when I see this, I am so happy.
Right.
So click, click on this link, dude, click on this link and go to the GitHub repo and look at the, um, look at the demo that he has on there.
Um, it, it, it brings up this interface and it's the perfect hybrid of having automation that you can customize and build your, in your own way.
Right.
Cause what we talked about on that episode was like, okay, 403 bypasser, like that's cool, but, but I don't have enough introspection into what it's actually doing for me to trust it.
So I'm still going to sit there and fuzz manually.
Right.
And, and like, you know, play around with stuff and tweak stuff and that sort of thing.
Um, what this thing does, and this is the beautiful part of it is it allows you to use AI to say, okay.
Um, I want to try, uh, these are the things I want to put in my 403 bypasser, my customized version of the 403 bypass.
I want to put all of the different requests.
I want to put a, um, you know, a dot, semi-colon slash, uh, at this path index.
I want to do this and this and this, and then the AI will automatically generate the code and give you a test interface where you can test to, to ensure that that method is being implemented the way that you want it to be implemented.
And then save it into your scan templates for the 403 bypasser.
Right.
Um, so, and then when you press scan, it'll say, okay, trying your HTTP method trick, trying your, you know, uh, dot, semi-colon slash trick, you know, and then you can go through and you can see the different, different, um, outputs for each one of those things that you would try.
Um, and it's, it's, it's extremely low friction because you're just using natural language to tell the AI to generate the code, which gets loaded into the template.
And it's very high integrity because you can still see everything that's being checked and have assurance that, oh, I don't have to go back there and manually check this because I can just see it right here.
And I just, I just, I love that.
I love that so much because, um, it, it's something that I can trust and it's something that has so low friction for me to implement and then have saved off for the future.
Any, anytime I need to do 403 bypasses in the future.
Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah.
And, um, we're finally getting now to a point as well with the, with this, the plugins and stuff, like the ecosystem within Kaido that it's some, it's getting a lot better to manage stuff.
I just went in and I can now update plugins manually or like automatically, I guess, like you just go into the tab and you just click update.
Yep.
And everything is much more integrated now.
So finally.
Yeah.
I mean,
And there's a story too, you know, I mean, if you look at burp and you look at how long burp is on around and you look how long it's taken for some things to happen on there, this is how things are changing on Kaido.
You know, we thin boil off for Kaido.
We do.
It's a, it's a good product.
It is.
And there's lots of evolution happening in that ecosystem.
I'm actually working on a plugin right now that I'm super excited to release.
Um, hopefully we'll be able to release it within the next month or so.
But, um, there's a lot of dev going on right now and I'm getting very familiar with the Kaido, uh, APIs.
And I think, um, I've also the Kaido team is, is, uh, here's a little, I'm just leaking this, you know, as I do, uh, Kaido team is putting a lot of effort right now into the, the dev ecosystem, um, in, in Q4.
Um, and so I think as we're going to see a lot of really, really nice to haves come into place, um, and then make it really easy to dev front end and back end plugins in Kaido.
Lots of, um, lots of automation surrounding how do we get like a starter kit up and rolling?
How do we, you know, just have all the documentation in one spot?
How do we use AI to supplement that and say like, Hey, you know, uh, this is actually how it should be implemented and that sort of thing.
Um, it's just, I'm very excited for it.
The, this upcoming quarter, there's going to be a lot of progress there and I think it's going to result in an explosion of innovation, um, in, in the, in the plugin arena.
Which would be very exciting.
What, one, one thing we still got to solve though, is like, how, how do we, I mean, it's that, that age old problem with open source stuff is like, how do we continue to give incentives to people that, that are developing these plugins?
And I think one of the things that kind of sucks about the, the bug bounty community and the security community in general is we don't love to support.
Uh, you know, financially, a lot of these projects and that we use.
Um, and so I think I'll just give another shout out cause I support Bebex on, on GitHub and, you know, give the, use the GitHub subscriber feature.
Um, and I think if you're using, if you're using plugins, if you're using, um, stuff like that, especially if it's directly leading to monetary gain for you through bug bounty.
Then maybe like chuck 25 bucks to your, to your, uh, you know, friendly plugin developer, because that will do a lot for their, their motivation to continue to develop their plugin.
Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely.
Um, all right, man.
We got a couple more things here on the list.
Um, we got the, oh, this one was really cool.
So, um, CSP bypass.com.
Did you see this?
Yeah.
So that was the other one I was going to bring up was, uh, CSP bypass.com.
This was from.
So it's a Rennie pack.
You want Rennie pack?
Yeah.
So Rennie pack, I don't know.
Well, it's on GitHub, right?
So it's just like, oh my God, it was updated 42 minutes ago.
So awesome.
Um, yeah.
So there's basically just a list of CSP bypasses and, uh, and it's CSV.
It's nothing even that crazy.
Um, and, um, yeah, it's, uh, it's just a collection of CSV bypasses.
And I guess you just, if you were trying to bypass CSP and you're like, I need, you know,
there's that CSP tool that, that one that everybody knows from Google, the CSP evaluator.
And it's like so close to being useful because you'll go and you'll put your whole CSP in
there and it'll be like, Hey, there's this domain on youtube.com that's vulnerable to
CSP.
And you're like, great.
Let's go.
What is it?
Yeah.
And it's like, I don't know.
It just is.
We're not going to tell you that.
Yeah.
This is that last step, right?
Um, you know, so you go CSP buys it, bypasses, you go youtube.com and Hey, there you go.
Script source, youtube.com slash own bed question mark callback equals alert one.
Yeah.
And there's your CSP bypass for YouTube.
So this is super, super helpful.
One of those, uh, those tools you just throw in your back pocket.
Well, I think it's been good to see the community come around it as well.
Right?
Like, like there've been a lot of community contributions, people going back through all their reports
and like grabbing all the CSP bypasses that they've ever used and loading them into this.
Um, the, the thing is with this, there's a couple of things that I, that I would like
to say with regards to this, right?
Like, obviously it's awesome.
And I'm so glad that we have it.
Um, some of these are not actual, you know, bypasses, right?
Uh, they, they are.
Jason, uh, Jason P callback interfaces.
Right.
And some of them don't have even the ability to use like a dot.
Um, cause we saw that research.
I think it was related to WordPress related stuff where, um, you know, it is possible for
you to exploit a, a CSP related, um, or a CSP bypass of sorts, just using a Jason P callback
functionality by, by hijacking the dot click function.
Um, and, and you can essentially say like, if you're able to, uh, provide a.
Arbitrary length callback function.
And that callback function can contains dots.
You can say, you know, window dot parent dot child dot child dot child dot child dot, you
know, whatever, find the delete account button dot click it because, um, you know, JavaScript
will take any parameters, you know, that are in there.
It just doesn't care about the parameters.
It'll just click the button and delete your account or whatever.
Right.
Or do like an OAuth authorization or something like that.
If it's on the same origin.
Um, and, and so, you know, definitely categorizing Jason P related functionality is, is massively
helpful.
Um, but I did go through here and I was looking at some of them and like, some of
these don't even have like dots.
You can't even put a dot.
You can't put a slash.
You can't do a function call.
Um, it's just, you know, the typical Jason P callback interface, which actually isn't
super helpful, uh, as far as I know.
Um, so definitely something nice to have, have would be to categorize each of these by
like ability by flexibility or like maybe what character set they support, um, uh, in the
Jason P callback.
And then, um, also, uh, the other thing that I, that I had with regards to this is it would
be really cool to combine CSP evaluator and this right.
Where you can say, okay, here are all the domains in my CSP, which of these domains match
a known bypass.
Um, so I think that's some pretty easy dev work to do.
I think we'll probably see it at some point come into this.
Uh, especially since this has been open sourced.
Um, someone should probably definitely go in there and like build in that parser and then
just compare it to the list of all the bypasses that are done.
Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, I think this would be a good opportunity to, I mean, you could even make another tool
out of just tying these things together or maybe the tool, the tool developers could,
uh, have a little discord chat and combine or, you know, integrate functionality with each
other, but definitely there, there's sort of an easy win here where, uh, at minimum as
a hacker, you could manually use both of these tools together.
And if you want to streamline your process, you could automate them together.
And if you want to streamline everybody else's process, you can release that.
Yeah.
Yeah, for sure.
Um, all right.
So I actually, I probably should have clustered this one with the other one.
Um, but let me, I'm going to jump down to this like arbitrary read, right?
On, uh, llama.cpp by side quest for a second.
Um, this is, this was a little bit of a weird one and this isn't stuff that we normally talk
about on the bug bounty podcast quite as much.
Um, but I really wanted to shout this out because I think that it, one is relevant to AI stuff,
which is very, um, very hot right now.
And I think that I've used llama multiple times.
And I think if anybody's interested in doing offline AI stuff that they're familiar with
this.
Um, and there's a pretty serious vulnerability in, uh, the llama server, the RPC server.
And it was very odd because it almost looked intentional.
Like essentially this RPC server, which is unauthed was exposing primitives where you could
essentially supply memory addresses and, and just allocate, you know, onto the heap and
read from specific, like you could literally give it a memory address and it would, you know,
read from that.
And it's like, what?
Um, and it's so wild.
Yeah.
So this is, this, it was really interesting because the, the guy that did the writeup on
it, side quest, um, I was watching some of it because it's a very good example for me,
uh, as a, as a primarily web hunter, um, how this sort of exploitation process works once
you've established the primitives, because, um, the RPC protocol is essentially the primitives
that you would normally need to trigger these exploits, right?
And normally you've got to go find an arbitrary read and arbitrary write, that sort of thing.
The RPC protocol was pretty much just exposing that.
Um, so it, it, the process was him taking this, you know, Python crafting this Python file to
use these RPC primitives to trigger code execution.
And it was like, it's like an hour long, you know, an hour and some change.
Um, and I think it's, it's a really cool example of that exploitation without having to find that
extra layer of like, all right, how do I not crash it?
And like, how do I isolate these specific, um, primitives, uh, and then build the exploit?
So definitely a cool piece of work there.
Yeah.
You know, this reminds me of, um, early on in my bug bounty career, one of the first
bugs that I found was a RPC server vault, uh, in a crypto project.
And if you don't know, a lot of crypto projects, they use this thing called the JSON RPC.
It's kind of similar thing, but that's like how you would like talk with your wallet and
stuff.
And there was this RPC call called delete.
And literally you would call it and it would just delete the entire server wallet.
And I was like, I don't know why this exists, but it's there.
And like, yeah, they were like, Oh wow.
Thanks for catching that.
Like, we don't know why it was there.
Yeah, dude, that's, that's crazy.
I think there's a lot of stuff hiding in these non HTTP related protocols and it's scary to
try to investigate them for a lot of people.
But, um, I think when you take, take the dive, it's, it's very friendly.
I, and just, just to quote some of the, uh, the stuff from this, this YouTube video, you
know, he's looking at this protocol and he's like, yeah, it's just like, you know, one,
one integer is like a, is like the, what call you're going to do.
And then there's like the, the message length and then the message.
And that's it.
You know, it's just a very simple binary protocol that took like five lines of code for him
to implement, you know, the send, the send call function.
Um, and so I think it's not as scary as everyone, or maybe I shouldn't project it to everyone
as many, as, as I think it could be.
And as many, I think web pest, pen testers believe it to be, um, to actually dive deep
on this stuff.
Um, and I just, I just, I mean, it goes back to that, like that barrier thing, right.
Of, you know, every, every hacker hits the same barrier that you're hitting, whether it's
setting up the software, learning the documentation, whatever.
And if you decide that you're going to push through that and you're going to learn through
and you're going to grit and, you know, head down and do it, then you, you get past where
everybody else stopped.
Yeah.
Yeah, for sure.
Um, the, the other little takeaway that I wanted to talk about on this topic was I think so,
and this is just very, very wide conjecture, but I was listening to the Lex Friedman podcast
on, um, the, that they did recently with the cursor AI team.
And, uh, it was very interesting because they were talking about optimizing stuff with the
LLMs at a very low level.
Um, and then I, I just, you know, the next day saw this where it's like, okay, you've got
this pretty well-respected, um, you know, LLM entity here, uh, that is exposing these primitives
to an RPC, you know, and by RPC.
So I think, you know, I'll just throw this conjecture out there.
I think some of these LLM related things may in, in, in the pursuit of performance may start
exposing some, some much lower level, um, functionality via some of these protocols.
Uh, cause I know that that's what the cursor team was talking about is optimizing at a much
lower level.
Um, and, and then we, we see this right here with LLM as well.
Um, so when you're investing, so I think the way that I've approached AI related targets at
this point has been a lot of like, you know, almost like red teaming the AI sort of approach.
Right.
And that's surely that is necessary as agents become more prevalent and you actually
weaponize these, these, uh, LLM models to, to, you know, do stuff.
But, um, I think if we want to take a more technical approach, which is very attractive
to me because of the wishy-washy nature of AI, like I don't really like red teaming AI
cause it's just so wishy-washy.
Um, if we want to take a more technical approach, then we can look deeper and deeper and see
if they're exposing any of these lower level primitives that might be used for optimization
of the LLM to get snappier response times like you see in cursor.
Yeah.
I will say like one of the things that bothers me a lot about testing with AI and like trying
to do adversarial stuff with AI is that you can get down a rabbit hole where it gets like
stuck with all this context that you've been testing with for whatever.
And if you just make a new chat, it can behave completely different.
And like, it's like as you know, a reset basically where you can sort of re path it to in the
direction that you want simply just based on the fact that it doesn't have the context from
the previous attempts.
And that can be very, very frustrating to go back and forth with.
I think.
Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
It can.
Yeah.
I think, I don't know if I'm ready to say it on the, I guess I'll say it on the podcast
just because that's how I do.
But I think definitely within the next year or two, I would like to experiment more with
this lower level exploitation stuff.
I think I've spent a lot of time on web and I think there is overlap between web and some
of this, this, you know, binary exploitation stuff that, that it would be really helpful
for me to be able to utilize my web skills, to be able to interact with some of these
sort of things and understand what's happening a little bit better at that lower level.
So I think I'm going to go back after this episode and rewatch this, this exploitation
video and, and see what I can take away from it.
Because I think this is a really cool example of, of how you can do that.
Yeah.
Yeah, for sure.
All right.
Last one that we had on the list for, for today was just a helpful little WAF bypass that
I came across.
Um, and this was under an article entitled, XSS WAF bypass one payload for all.
And, uh, this is by a guy named Edra.
Um, and I'm looking through here and there's some, there's some interesting bypasses in here.
So definitely check it out.
Obviously they're going to get whack-a-mold, you know, like, like the whole, um, WAF bypass
game goes.
Uh, but I, I liked the principle of essentially weaponizing encodings against WAFs themselves
because WAFs by nature need to be able to deal with various, uh, layers of encoding because
they don't know what they're dealing with on the backside of them.
Right.
Uh, on the backside of the, uh, uh, the WAF.
Um, and, and so this whole concept of using, uh, different levels of encoding with the same
entity, in this case, a, a double quote, I think is, is pretty attractive.
So the, the exploit that he released was, or the, the bypass that was released was, um,
X equals, and then double quote, and then a quote entity in HTML, and then another double
quote, and then, you know, an on air handler or whatever.
Um, and so they're, they're mixing that, you know, traditional, just double quote, plus
the HTML encoding to create a mismatch in perception from the server.
And, and the, the WAF thinks, okay, this is an X attribute and then an attribute that starts
with double quote and then goes to on air.
Right.
Whereas actually the, the middle piece is actually encapsulated inside the HTML attribute and
the on air definition is, um, is its own attribute itself, which will trigger.
Um, so it's just trying to take these principles and bring them up at, to a higher level and say,
what can we, what can we learn from this specific WAF bypass?
Um, is, is that, uh, creating an odd, uh, number of these, these specific entities, right?
You've got double quote, double quote, double quote three.
Um, and then sort of creating that mismatch between various HTML entities, uh, encodings,
that sort of thing is, is pretty widely applicable, I think.
Yeah.
I, I mean, and again, you can just file this one into the, the, the notebook of bypasses
or put it included into the AI script and the 403 bypass or whatever, you know, like there's,
there's a ton of different, um, there's a ton of different little bypasses and little,
I don't know, gadgets coming out now that are so useful to have in the back pocket.
Um, I will say it's almost getting to a point now where I need some way to like organize
them and just test them all at the same time.
So I think those extensions that are like, you know, 403 bypass or that kind of stuff that
do a lot of different tests at once against a single target are pretty useful because it
makes it so I don't have to remember so many individual things.
Hmm.
Yeah.
And, and the, this article contains three, uh, bypasses for Imperva, Amazon, WAF and Akamai,
um, that all utilize this specific functionality.
And, and as we've, I think also just lately with, uh, Shazer and with some of the other research
that's been coming out surrounding HTML entities, I think HTML entities in particular as an encoding,
uh, are, are pretty helpful because there's so many ways to represent the same character,
even, even with these like sort of, um, double character, uh, ones that we've seen where it's
like, okay, you get like a less than sign and some junk, you know, that sort of thing.
Um, I think we'll be very helpful for, for bypassing WAFs in the, in the future.
Um, all right, man, I think that's, that's all I had.
I got this, you know, I'm going to push this next one to, to next week.
So I think that's all I had on the list.
You got anything else before we close off this one?
I think that was it, dude.
All right.
GG.
Peace.
That's the pod.
And that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking.
Thanks so much for listening.
And if you want more critical thinking content, head over to ctbb.show slash discord, join the
discord.
There's lots of great conversations and chats going on over there.
And if you want to support the show, there's the discord subscriber tiers, which give you
access to masterclasses, AMAs, hack alongs, exclusive scripts, and an exclusive chat channel
with us.
We'll see you there.
Thank you.